Here we go. A lot of questions to go through first and make sure you chat in your questions as we go. If you think of something.
So again, reminder, you have questions between the Zoom calls. Look at the log posts on our regular website. Certainly utilize our member site. We're getting a number of people that is still haven't logged into the member site.
So you're missing out. There's a lot of good information there and we're giving you updates on there.
So the paper patient membership site is important for you to get on because that's where we'll share our announcements.
So if you worked with us two weeks ago last week, I was gone.
So you want to see the announcement that was gone last week.
But you'll also have seen the announcement that we have a new Zoom call on Mondays.
We didn't do it this week because obviously it was before I could July but every Monday at noon.
So you can ask questions through the Zoom again. Feel free to ask questions.
And we'll look at those questions to if she can answer them. She'll answer them her Zoom call.
If she feels like it's more appropriate for me to answer that question, she'll just push it over to me.
And I will try to answer it best in my ability on the Wednesdays of course. Now you have two Zoom calls.
So just to help save on your need to make personal appointments, save on finances for you.
We're trying to be best equipped with the tools that you need to continue with your protocol and continue having the best results that we hope to get.
So utilize the Zoom call on Mondays at noon. Those will also be recorded and those will also be posted on the membership site as well.
If you've added a page on the membership site for genetic reviews to learn more about genetics.
And those are going to be done via Zoom call a specific time each week. If you have not had your genetic review, it will be on Thursdays at two.
Please do not jump on that Zoom call until we email you that your genetics are done.
So that will let you know.
The newer program said test made me slightly sick on different days, but not a big deal. Let's talk about that a little bit.
There is a blog post.
But our website, we go back to the website and you search good pain, bad pain. There's a blog post that I created a while back about different symptoms that one could have when they have a serious diagnosis.
Sometimes the symptoms of pain or discomfort can be a good symptom. And with change in the frequencies increasing pain, I would say that's most likely a very good symptom that is that it's helping your body kill that cancer.
And we said, as I should mention that I still bleed while you're at 80. I drink a gallon of clean water daily. So I'm sure the blood is diluted becomes visible at the last few dribbles of your nation.
I wonder if the bleeding is because the cancer growth is pulling off the wall on the bladder. This person has bladder cancer or because it's growing.
There's really no way to answer that question. Have you had other bladder cancer patients with similar symptoms during treatment is my question, unknowable. And do I just trust our father's good and sovereign will through the unknown. Yes, there's there's a lot of truth to that.
And a godly perspective in this by this person, which is encouraging.
We don't know everything. We can make some speculations. Could the bleeding be cut be because the cancer is growing. Well, that is possible.
Typically, a growing cancer is necessarily going to be a bleeding cancer. So I don't think that the bleeding would necessarily indicate that cancer is growing.
And the bleeding could mean the vessels are closer to the surface because your immune system is killing some of the cancer mass.
So, I mean, I would think more of a encouragement to that we don't go forward.
Keep praying through this. And again, trusting God's good and sovereign will for our lives.
Next question has anyone heard of harm and dependence for EMF protection? If so, what are your thoughts?
Personally, I've not heard of this brand. There are a lot of different brands out there.
Well, another patient brought up another brand to us that we may start carrying at our store.
We use the heat run brand right now. Some of these EMF protection things for phones and such and safe sleep protection for your phone.
I think it's the best protection for your phone. But there are lots of other brands out there. It's difficult to test them. So they referenced HRV, which is heart rate variability testing as proof of their efficacy.
I see heart rate variability testing referred to frequently when reading about energy medicine.
What are your thoughts on this test heart rate variability can measure a person's parasympathetic sympathetic balance heart rate variability is very good to there's different.
Different instruments out there. One's called heart math that the other doctor friend of night uses with some of his patients in office that you could help kind of train your brain to be more parasympathetic dominant calm anxiety and things.
There's some other tools out there that could help with that too.
Is there a test to determine bad or high estrogen levels? I think that's what's happening to my 50 year old husband. He seems to have those types of symptoms.
Would CDG estrogen be an option? If so, how much? So CDG estrogen is a dim product. It also has calcium degluterate. It also has I3C and I think it's a good product. Certainly males can take that.
Typically, those are thought dim products are thought to be used solely for females, which is totally incorrect. Males are exposed to just as many zero estrogens as women are.
Are exposed to from foods and plastics in your environment. So environmental bad estrogens that you're exposed to, males are exposed to just as many as females that affect if you're talking about food exposures.
They're exposed to more because they tend to eat more. So males should and could take dim products as well. So a dim product is a product that helps pull up bad estrogens.
Is there a test to see where your estrogen levels are the Dutch test? This is the Dutch brand Dutch test, but Dutch tests really is an acronym for dried urine hormone test.
There are several labs that do the Dutch test. This is for precision labs. I think this gives you the nicest readout of any of the Dutch tests.
Doctors data has a Dutch test. ZRT has a Dutch test. There's other Dutch test out there. But that is the best hormone test out there is a dried urine hormone test. And it gives you readout of all your, or many, many of your estrogen and progesterone and testosterone.
There are four modes in their precursors, and there are intermediate metabolites above those hormones in that test. That is the way you would measure that.
We have these for sale on our site. If you search Dutch test on our store, you'll see that this little symbol of this test. I think it's like three or 50 bucks or something like that.
If you're a kid, you just do it at home, to urine test, you do it at home, send it into the lab comes the prestand envelope to go to the lab, takes about a week or so to get back to very valuable test. It can tell you if you have a lot of bad estrogens or your low end progesterone or your high end testosterone or low end testosterone or whatever you're dealing with that could give you.
I can give you a real nice readout. One of our breast cancer patients do that test. Have you heard of using curcumin IVs for breast cancer? Yes, it's not just for breast cancer. There's people that do curcumin IVs for all sorts of cancers.
You could do curcumin IVs just for inflammation, typically curcumin.
It's got of as an anti inflammatory. It is a flavidoid and it does decrease inflammation. It's one of the best things to decrease inflammation in the brain.
For people with post-concussive syndrome, taking high dose curcumin or in a curcumin IV can be very beneficial.
Curcumin also has hundreds of different studies showing its efficacy for cancers, all sorts of cancers. So using curcumin IVs for any type of cancer can be beneficial.
Curcumin in the forms that we see it in today is very absorbable though. So to eat it in an IV isn't always necessary.
It is, you know, you do a curcumin IV from a cost perspective, it could cost you $150 or something like that. Some people are doing IVs and it's cost you a couple hundred dollars to go into IVs.
Well, you could buy a whole lot of bottles of curcumin for that. So from a cost perspective, probably not.
If cost isn't a factor for you and you're getting IVs, vitamin Cs and things and they'll add curcumin for relatively inexpensive price. There can be benefit to it.
If you do remember, though, that all your nutrients, whether you're getting a bit IV, you're taking life of somal curcumin or you're taking it in whatever form you have, you get it into the bloodstream, it has a half life in the bloodstream, all your nutrients have a half life.
People know off the top of my head what the half life of curcumin is, but it's going to dissipate, you know, shortly. So if you do a curcumin IV every Monday, let's say, buy the next Monday, you have none in your bloodstream, maybe in a couple of days you have none in your bloodstream, maybe in a day you have none in your bloodstream.
So if you're not also taking curcumin on a regular basis, this is why I tell you if you're, if you're taking three a per day of something where it's very true, you should split it up throughout the day as best you possibly can.
So because all these, if you take three of them, it's supposed to take three a day and you're taking them all at eight o'clock in the morning, you may have none in your bloodstream at five o'clock at night.
Well, let us not do any good for the cellular standpoint, because you have none circulated in your bloodstream at five o'clock at night, tell the next morning at eight o'clock in the morning when you take them again.
So you want to spread out your supplements as best you can because of that thing, the idea that all supplements have a half life in your bloodstream and then in your tissues will cost efficacy of doing curcumin IVs.
And then since you're certainly not doing them on a daily basis.
You have to think through that.
CBD oil and breast cancer, same thing CBD oil can be good for breast cancer and any cancer as well.
Could you please chat about DMSO added with frankincense applied topically.
That's a stop the question right there, so when you add DMSO, dimethyl sulfoxide to anything.
It will help drive it into the tissue.
So DMSO became big in the seventies as an anti inflammatory that you could actually make it home with different household chemicals.
Now you can buy DMSO on Amazon.
It's a liquid.
It's like a water.
It's a sulfur compound.
So if you put DMSO on your skin, because you're let's say on your knee, because you hurt your knee.
And you put like a teaspoon of DMSO rub it on your knee.
It you will soon taste like a garlic he tasted your mouth because of the sulfur.
It absorbs very quickly through your skin.
It will also bring with it anything that's on your skin.
So if you have like toxic lotion on your skin, you put DMSO over.
You're going to drive toxic lotion into your skin.
So you always want to clean your skin that you're going to put DMSO on.
You don't want to have sun 10 lotion that's not good for you.
And you're driving it in with DMSO.
You don't want to use toned 10 lotion.
That's not good for you.
And you're driving it in with DMSO.
You're going to have sun 10 lotion. That's not the free video.
And secondly, can you use the DMSO with frankincense, or an essential oil.
We'll help drive that essential oil or anything you mix with frankincense with DMSO.
Or you put DMSO over that substance will drive it into the skin.
So, many times, DMSO is used as a driver.
Now, DMSO by itself is an anti-inflammatory substance,
so that's why I said using it over D-paid, but it can,
so putting it on your head for a brain tumor like glioblastoma,
can have some benefit, whether it will absorb right through the
skull or not, because you have your skin, and then you have
your lower dermal layers, and then you have your skull bone,
and then you have your duramotter and piamotter.
Those are the layers that cover the brain.
Whether DMSO will help drive frankincense applied to the scalp
through all those layers to the brain is questionable,
but certainly if it will help you absorb it into the blood vessels
the scalp, and that can help in many ways.
So, I don't think that it would actually, you're not driving frankincense into the brain
when you use DMSO, but you're certainly helping it drive into the
vasculature underneath the skin there. So, all right, next question.
Oh, this was interesting, an idea for the store.
It'd be really helpful to have my protocol handy online, maybe either in a pop-up
where I could click on an item to see it in the store, then add it to my cart,
or with an option to click one button in from my entire protocol into my cart,
then I could tweak my order from there. I thought that was a great idea.
Said there is no app out there that does that because we searched for it after we saw this great idea.
We do have an app on our store where you can put things in an auto ship,
so that's called a subscription. So, you can add your, if you do this one time,
when you first get your protocol, you can add it to a subscription, and then you can always change
your subscription too. So, let's say, oh, I need to take X amount of these a day, so I'll need
X amount of these a month. So, I'll order two bottles a month of these, and then I need
fully these many amount of these. I only need one bottle of those a month, so you could add it
to a subscription on our store. We've had that for quite some time, but that company is always
improving that app. Next question. I have all over my body aches every morning. It feels like
joint muscle bones, and it slowly goes away through the day, but not completely. I've been off
chemo for about a month, and the body aches have not gone away. I use the right frequencies every day,
but it was wondered if the body aches could be related to using the right. I realized that there are
other factors that could be contributed to these body aches, age, arthritis, food, supplements,
and the need to detox. What do you suggest? I focus on first and resolving these body aches.
So, when you have something like this, I wouldn't think that this is necessarily a quote good
paid, like we talked about in that earlier slide, where it was very specific to the cancer site itself.
I would say this probably has very little to do with the right itself, has more to do with needing
to support detoxification pathways more than anything else. There's too many possibilities
to this without getting very specific to what this person is dealing with.
I would say this has very little to do with arthritis, and maybe possibly probably doesn't
have anything to do with food. I would say more has to do with detoxification. I would focus on
detox pathways. I would think of trying to use the ion pro wave programs, make sure you're doing that.
I would say with just general achy joint muscle bones, just kind of feeling achy all over,
you also want to think of magnesium too, so maybe doing some magnesium baths would be helpful.
Epsom cell baths could be helpful. Sonas could be helpful too. That's what I would concentrate on.
Food sensitivities can cause this. You see this kind of joint muscle, bone, body ache, fatigue,
tiredness with gluten sensitivities quite common too, so that's a possibility too.
I have a family friend that had brain cancer and gave us information of fermented soy
by Hayland, soy health products. She is convinced that this shrug her tumor. It is fermented soybean,
oral nutritional beverages that are manufactured with nitrogenation process,
growth organically, and minerals, so else. We use this product. We have this on our store,
and this, so understand I wrote about Hayland in my book, Stop by the Cancer. I have several blog posts
about Hayland and fermented soy in the difference from fermented soy to soy are like 180 degrees.
So fermented soy can have advantages especially with estrogen receptor positive cancers,
as fermented soy has been shown to dislodge the bad estrogens from the beta receptors,
from the estrogen beta receptors. That's the problem with bad estrogens. They attach to the estrogen
beta receptors, or we'll use to be called the Hale receptors, and the estrogen beta receptors
are an apoptotic receptor. We did it stimulates apoptosis, and then it's blocking apoptosis by attaching
to that. For fermented soy has been shown to dislodge the bad estrogen from the estrogen beta
estrogen receptors. So we used to be able to get fermented soy in a
lawsuit called Sanogastral. A company stopped making that, and Hayland has been around for years.
We've used them for a long time. They're great. It's a great product.
Oh, second part of that question. What are your thoughts of adjusting breast belt?
I have seen studies and tweeted on this. We haven't done much study of that. I don't know
the pros and cons of that. Here's I had to cut off this question because the person's name was out
here. It says, his doctor is recommending the op-tune device. So the op-tune device is a device. It's
actually a PEMF type device that attaches to your head. This is for brain cancers. So the op-tune
device works with certain brain cancers by pushing the frequency. It's an electrical frequency.
It's not a frequency like the right frequencies program that the cancer is just an electrical
frequency to change the charge of the cell for a couple of reasons. I can explain it to you.
A matter of fact, I do explain it in a blog post. So you can look at the blog post about that or
optude.com. I haven't looked at that for a long time, but I'm pretty sure they have some pretty
cool little videos on there too. The idea is that your cells during replication process, your cells
go through what's called mitosis where the DNA have to split to opposite sides of the cell
in order to duplicate. What pushing electrical frequency across them hinders that splitting of the
DNA and can slow down replication. It doesn't kill cancer cells, but it can slow down replication.
This device came out about five years ago or so. Additionally, got approved only for astrocytomas.
I think it's approved for different types of brain cancers. We've had several patients that have
used it. You can use this along with your right. Because this is done, people are using this 24-7
neck shape their head and put this thing on. It sticks on your head. It doesn't interfere with
your right frequencies and your right frequencies. Don't interfere with this. They're completely
different modes of operation. Question about grounding pads or grounding sheets, which is better.
We do have a couple videos on grounding pads and grounding sheets on the member's only page. So
please look at those. In brief, though, the grounding pad that comes with your right machine,
you use with your ion pro weight. Put it on the back, on your back, while you're doing your ion pro
weight, put it on the chair, sit on it partially or lean back on it. It just helps drive the frequencies
through your body. Grounding sheets. Grounding sheets are put on your bed. We suggest if you use a
grounding sheet, you only use it on the lower half of your bed. So put it cross ways across your bed.
If you have a partner's wife, husband that sleeps with you. So both of you, the grounding sheet is
underneath the fitted sheet. And if it's only on the lower half of the bed, then theoretically it will
be about your pelvis and then down. Again, the negative about using a grounding sheet is the full
length of the bed is if you're sleeping with the right, holding it to your chest and you're on your
back, well, no harm, no foul. But if you roll on your side and the right ball balls right onto the
sheet, you're going to lose some of those frequencies. They're going to go towards the ground.
And you'll lose some of those frequencies. So that's where I tell people, mainly to use the
grounding sheets on the lower half of the bed if they use them or don't use them at all. So I don't
like it. True right? It's really big into the grounding sheets. And I don't know if he's really
big enough just to sell another product. But I just think through the a little bit differently
than he does. So I go through it on that video or detail. So remember to look at the members
site for updates and things. We'll try to keep you abreast to new things that are going on in the
clinic and new ideas that we have and new thoughts. All these will be reported and put up there as well.
So keep looking at the site for new changes and updates because we are changing that.
Okay. Any other questions? I've got one chat coming in here. Oh, nothing yet. So
somebody said they sent a question to the email. Let's see who it is right here.
All right. So I'll just read it to you. It says, when
rife protocol is changed by your office and after a few weeks, I get what I believe is a
Herk's reaction, crippling might be. We think this is a detox reaction. Pain is terrible. I
suspended the right to slow detox. Is that a good idea? Can I know? I mean,
you know, you typically are not going to get a Herk's type of reaction running cancel frequencies.
So anything is possible though. We just haven't seen that. So
I would also investigate other possibilities. I mean, just because you have cancer doesn't mean
that you can't contract live or something like that at the same time. So make sure you're
investigating other possibilities there. I don't think the cancer frequencies that we're
running at your program are going to cause a Herk's type of reaction to lead pain.
We really, we really might want to run a line test on you. That might be a good, that might be
a thought. The best line test out there, the most sensitive one, is the DNA connections test.
And I do have a, I believe I have a blog post on that on our cancer site. It might be on my
hope for line. But contact your liaison test is not really super cheap. But it's a really good
test for blind DNA and co-infections. And it will pick up a few pad lines. So when you get knee pain
that is crippling like that for no apparent reason. I have a hurt idea. I haven't twisted it
I haven't done anything like that. The first thing you think of is lonely. I've seen hundreds
of hundreds of lying patients. We could be wrong, but it might be good to look at that. Maybe it's
something's flareded. That's a very strong possibility. But talk to your liaison about that for sure.
Should we put the bulb of the right machine close to our bodies or on top of where the cancer is?
Well, hopefully you could do the same thing. So if you have a blood cancer like the leukemia,
where is the cancer? It's all over. It's a blood-based cancer. Multiple myeloma without any
bully interference yet. It's all over the place. Then phoma. Okay, now we're talking about a hard
cancer. So you could put it right over the cancer. If you have a brain cancer, certainly you could put
the bulb on the top of your head, but it's going to keep you awake. So if you hold the bulb close to
your tummy, close to your chest and you are able to put the covers over it, then the bulb won't keep
you awake at night. Even if you have brain cancer, those frequencies are getting to the brain.
I do have some brain cancer patients that do put the bulb right up by their head and they say,
oh, it doesn't keep me awake. Okay, well, it's not keeping you awake. You're closer it is to the cancer
of the matter. So that's the closer it begins to the cancer of the better, as long as it's not
keeping you awake. It'll be the appropriate answer to that. How long after applied black sand, do you have
to wait to shower? Or will you have to wear a hangator, each time I shower? You're not supposed to get it
for those who are doing black sand. You're not supposed to get it wet. So if you've got a little
damp or you've got water out there, really no harm, but getting it soaked is not appropriate. So
you're going to have to cover it each time you shower, or you're going to have to do something
appropriate to keep that away from the water. So yeah, sorry. Do baths on your back or heads and
knees. Oh, do baths on your back. So this is speaking from a person who's done lots of black
backs at black sand. And her experience is to keep the sand dry, do baths, you know, instead of showers,
your back or your knees, hands of these, speaking from somebody with a lot of experience. So
very good. Thank you. Can a clean liver supplement with no added synthetic iron increase
the low red blood cells for people who should not eat animal protein?
Baby, you know, clean liver supplements. I don't know if you're going to want a desiccated liver.
So can desiccated liver help increase red blood cells? Yeah, I can think so. Your red blood cells
aren't made in your liver. You bake red blood cells at your bone marrow. And there are
desiccated supplements for that. Baby desiccated spleen could help.
But a doubt that liver would help. If I test positive for live, do you treat that along with
curtain pull? Yes. So we would treat that with the right. So it's not uncommon. So I could go right
along, you know, can be a causative factor of cancer because it can certainly diminish your immune
response because your immune system just gets plummeted by line. So you could have had this
a long time ago and never do it. But tell you how many people have had live, you know,
for years and attributed their aches and pains and issues to aging or something else. And
it was alive or it's cold infections on. And the right is just the absolute best tool for that. So
yes, we just had a program that I just said you a different program. But yeah, so it is a valuable
thing to know to do. I have, I'm pretty sure, let me look on my website here for a talking.
I thought I had a DNA connection. You might have had to pull that off.
Nope. I have it on. So if you look at just search DNA in the search bar, you just start typing
DNA in here. You'll start CLC, the DNA connections, DNA line test information.
And you can click to see a sample report. It's a very simple test. It's a urine test that you do
at home too, which is kind of nice because we just said you can't. We did not mark up the price of that.
I think it's $700. That's the problem. This is pricey. But all the other line tests are very
expensive too. And there are things many times less accurate. But it's, you just write, actually,
we send you the kit and you can write the checkout to the to the lab as you send in the kits. So
we're pretty quick getting it back to. So it's, I think it's a value of a test to know if you've had
live past any other questions. I kind of a quiet group today. Why would stool smell like
moth balls? Why would stool smell like moth balls? Oh, good questions. Moth balls are made from
Nathlete. Nathlete is the components of Nathlete, the aromatic hydrocarbons found in coltar crude oil.
Maybe because you're taking charcoal. Let's see 10H8. That's the biochemical compounds to
benzene lades. More general and free in coltar. Good question. It occurs in essential oils of
numerous plants. Magnolia. Maybe that's it. Take it in essential oils. Magnolia is a product in
some of our, I know we have Magnolia in several of our products. That's interesting. Well, you probably
want to worry about mice in your colon. So that would be a good thing. That's the moth balls out of
cabin. Never had mice could actually have a cabin next year. So that was a problem. Could it be parasites
or they've got, although I don't think so. I'd never heard of that. I don't know. Not that I've heard of,
though. I don't think so. I would try to correlate it to maybe something you're taking. Maybe I
would say that you're taking essential oils that are absorbed. Any possible shortages of supplements
due to the threat of upcoming food shortages? Yes. We don't get pre-wording of that. I'll tell you,
the last two years we've had so many back orders on stock. It's just insane. Some companies are much better
pre-ordering things than other companies. I'll tell you, biotics research. I don't know who orders
their stuff, but they need to get fired. I'm sorry, but they're horrible. They have more stuff on
back order. All the time. All the time. I just don't get it. In some companies just are really good at
keeping things in stock and ordering, but it gets very frustrating when we, you know, there's things on
back order that something's just going back order. The collagen for morphine molecular went
on back order until end of October. It's like this gracious and morphine molecular is typically
really good at keeping things in stock. So, it's difficult. Nothing that we know of. So,
do you know whether tomorrow will be back to testing? I think they are back to testing now,
but they're being selective. So, you're going to have to contact them and say, are you accepting tests
and I would ask them daily if you could email them? I do know that I've had some patients send in tests
to them and they did get results back. So, I just think that they're so swamped, but I would just
keep asking if you can contact them. So, this person says it's been going on since the cancer
diagnosis. I think the smell of mothballs has been going on since the cancer diagnosis. I'm going
to investigate that. See if I can figure that out. I'll do some more research on that and see
looking up this cancer. Is this, and see who is this on? Is this on your, on your husband?
I'll get a little bit better idea on yourself. Okay. This person says I did email Navaro. They said
look at the website. The website says no, they're not accepting right now. Okay, so I'll look up that
mothball smell. I'll try to figure that out. I'm looking forward to the new PEMF
docu series coming soon from Dr. Talks. Do you have any new insights or thoughts on best PEMF
machines? I am ready to invest in the machine, but want to make sure I make the correct choice.
I have different, I have different opinions than Dr. Pollock a little bit, but not really, but he
doesn't really talk about cancer. So, when I talk to him, is it, you know, she and I talk on the phone,
we have the exact same opinion, but then when you listen to him talk in general,
he's not saying the same thing always. I'm actually in that docu series,
interviewed by him. I don't think the interview went really well because he's a little confused
between PEMF and right. He doesn't really fully understand the difference.
It's very different. So, PEMF is an electrical frequency. Right is light frequency and it is
a hundred percent completely different. PEMF machines, you can only vary the frequency.
You can't vary minutely. You can't change, you can't run a certain hertz on a PEMF device.
It's not possible. So, because it's an electrical frequency, it's a totally different wavelength,
and it's just, it's a hundred percent different. They're just two completely different tools,
and I don't know that he fully understands that. However, he's a great guy. And he, if you do buy
a machine from him, he has multiple different models that he will say the same thing
that you need a high-goose output machine. So, PEMF machines are rated on the Gauss output,
G-A-U-S-S. And the Gauss, you want a high-goose output machine for cancer.
So, we have a PEMF machine that we have on our website, which I think is the best PEMF machine
for the money, for the Gauss output for a whole unit. They're still, they're expensive. It's about
$9,000, but it's, it's, it goes to about six to 7,000 Gauss. And it's not like a, like an
in-clinic unit, like the PEMF machines that we used in our clinical, we saw patients in our clinic
that I still have. They are like a 35,000 Gauss output, but they also cost you $35,000.
So, on demand is a PEMF machine, but it's a very low-goose output machine. It's fine if you already
have a low-goose output machine, use it. It's better than nothing. But really, if you're looking to buy
a PEMF machine, you haven't spent the money on one yet. You want to buy as high a Gauss output
machine as possible. If you look at our store, we have what I think is the best machine for the money.
Now, the last time I talked to Dr. Pollock, which was about three months ago, he had one similar to
that. It's all going to be about the same price because you paid per basically for the Gauss.
But there's a lot of low-goose output machines that cost the same amount and they're just a lot of hype.
So, if you were going to spend the money on a low-goose output machine, I would tell you to get an IMRS
machine. We don't sell those. That's a low-goose output machine. They run about $4,000.
If you want to get the better high-goose output machine, get the one that we have on our store.
We have a lot of people that use it and have been happy with it. We've had one person with a problem
with it. I think it got resolved by the company. So, yeah, that's PEMF machines. If you look at our store
search PEMF and you'll see the machine. So, if you just looked at PEMF on our store,
you will pull it out. It's called the PEMF whole unit. You can get it in a carried-case tote model,
or you can get it in a desktop model. All right. Any other questions? All right. So, we'll say goodbye
for today. We'll be back next week. Remember to submit your questions if you can on the member site.
It's easier that way to make sure we catch them. And jump on the different Zoom calls. And
remember that added one. All that's available. All the links to that are also available on the member site.
All right. Bye-bye everybody.